bonjour c'est bérénice marlohe retrouver
mois sur filmsactu
c'est vrai que la scène de casino royale
que je trouve
drôle et en même temps qui est
emblématique des james bond
parce qu'elle allie un peu de noirceur
et d'humour et je tends ils sont très
forts pour ça
surtout les anglais c'est quand james
bond est à moitié nue en train d'être
torturés par le méchant et que et qui
lui dit
maintenant le monde va va vous connaître
comme l'homme qui est qui et qui est
morte et bientôt mort en mai grattant
les cojones où les roubignoles s et je
trouve ça très drôle parce que fo le
sait c'est un savoir-faire d'allier
comme ça humour et avec un côté un peu
un peu noir à la old boys
et voilà je pense que c'est un
personnage qui est attachant et émouvant
il transporte avec elle une sorte de
tragédie comme est comme il est dit très
brièvement dépendant pendant le scénario
qui fait illusion un peu à sa vie passée
et que c'est un personnage qui est
quelque part comme les personnages de
racine au théâtre qui est donc une sorte
de cri qui transporte une tragédie et
comme si un destin était scellé
et quand elle rencontre la première fois
james bond tout d'un coup cet homme
après silva c'est le deuxième homme de
sa vie qu'il peut représenter voiture
virtuellement une délivrance est un un
changement dans dans sa vie pour moi je
pense que vraiment quand elle rencontre
j'ai un monde pour elle c'est un vrai
espoir d'être d'être sauvés mais il ya
toujours quand il ya toujours en dans le
temps ce personnage une conscience que
la vie est pas est pas rose donc c'est
pas un personnage naïf
donc je pense qu en sous couche en ali a
toujours cette réalise cette
connaissance de la réalité que et que
cécile va être un personnage réellement
très dangereux donc voilà c'est un
mélange d'espoir soudain grâce à
l'apparition de james bond en ayant
cette cette expérience de vie de
connexion à l' arrêt à la réalité au
monde qu'elle connaît depuis depuis
depuis sa naissance
j'avais très peur qui viendrait empêcher
la main
vous avez fait une apparition d'acier
dans notre petit mail au jeu trop
embrouillé le scénario ça a du bon côté
a 30 ans monsieur
c'est vrai qu'en lisant le script
c'est ce qui m'a plu et c'est ce qui me
plaît aussi à des personnages dans les
germes monde sait qu'ils sont en bio en
tout cas on peut jouer là dessus et je
voulais vraiment ont joué sur ces plans
là je voulais qu'elle est la première
fois qu on la voit une dangerosité et
c'est pour ça que j'ai travaillé sur
pour qu'elles soient le plus complexe
possible sur la masculinité et la
féminité aussi l'animalité et notamment
le chimaera que j'ai découvert donc dans
le script ce nom là qui réplique une
référence au bateau qu'ils prennent dans
le film et c'est une créature mythique
qui est un mélange de dragon de panthère
et de serpents et je voulais vraiment
travailler là dessus c'est à l'essai
sorte de lenteur et de présence et que
le dragon c'est ce qui me plaisait c'est
qu'ils tuent de loin sans toucher et je
voulais qu'elle soit vraiment habité au
niveau du regard et et tout ça deux par
cette qualité et comme vous l'avez dit
très bien que le début ça que qu'on ne
sache jamais vraiment si elle va la voir
ou le tuer ou le sauté dans les bras ou
et cet univers des james bond s'y prête
à merveille donc c'est vraiment là
dessus que je voulais travailler
travailler on oriente big 8 et je
voulais qu'elle soit un mélange de chef
de mafia et 2,2 et de femmes en détresse
ça va ce mec était très intéressant chez
elle ce cette sorte de masque de
maquillage de coiffure presque geisha et
j'aime beaucoup cette idée du com comme
dans la vie du masque social c'est à
dire qu'on n'en trouve pas tout c'est
toutes ses couleurs dans la vie et
ensuite il ya un masque qui qui s'en va
ou pas toujours mais on se sent qu'il ya
une réalité intérieure qui ce qui se
passe et je voulais vraiment qu'elle
soit un vrai êtres humains avec toute la
complexité des émotions ça amène en même
temps que que cette qualité que j'aime
beaucoup dans les dents les personnages
des maisons qu'ils sont un peu de
théâtre théâtre théâtrale théâtraux j'ai
pas compris ou en couleur ou en couleur
et cette manière et ça permettait aussi
d'avoir une aisance quand elle marche
qu'elle soit un peu plus un peu plus
haut que dans la réalité c'est à dire un
peu se déplacer de manière très lente et
et glamour mais en ayant une humanité
une connexion avec ses réalités
intérieur très forte
que savez-vous de la peur je le connais
tout pas celle qui vous attend
je me rappelle d'un moment quand nous
sommes dans les dents les dans les
immeubles en face de l'autre et au
moment de l'arrivée et sam mendes donc
essai était là avec son combo avec son
écran et j'arrivais cramée regarder il a
chanté le hennissement l'on joue à dix
avec berry moi oh ça c'est pour ces pour
situer un peu des réalisateurs et
ensuite j'avais daniel craig en face qui
qui ont entre entre les prises commença
donc c'était d'aider des verrières à la
danse et à douala ii et tout le monde et
qui c'est qui danse comme ça donc
c'était c'était c'était ça qui était
formidable sur ce tournage c'est que non
seulement l'expérience de travail avec
des gens extrêmement humble et
talentueux mais qui se prennent pas au
sérieux qu'ils prennent au travail très
sérieusement mais qui ne se prennent pas
au sérieux et ça ça va te c'était
vraiment très très chouette
j'ai toujours rêvé de jouer en anglais
et de jouer dans des films américains ou
anglais comme non mais on est très
friand au petit buffet en france cdc
film donc même avant avant james bond
j'étais parti déjà à los angeles pour
commencer à faire les démarches pour
avoir des visas est donc maintenant j'ai
un agent américain ou que je reçois des
scripts anglais américains et c'est vrai
que ça me plaît énormément
et si j'ai ainsi j'ai inscrits en
français qui me plaît à ce sera avec
plaisir aussi de de faire ça mon grand
fantasme c'est le joker d'heath ledger
ou gary oldman dans les ions et c'est
vrai que ce sont toujours ces rôles à
borderline ou c'est ça permet une telle
liberté intérieure 2d d'essayer des
choses sans avoir de limites puisque le
personnage en lui-même est un peu fou et
j'adore j'adore ce genre de personnage
j'ai pu
pendant pendant le film pour un tournage
du film ce cas il faut le faire une
audition à los angeles pour pour lui et
avoir le plaisir de travailler avec lui
on a tourné à austin texas
c'est l'histoire d'un triangle amoureux
peut même les acteurs sont pas trop au
courant de ce crime tu es un très beau
casting d'une terrasse malik qui est
absolument fabuleux natalie portman
rennes goslin michael fassbender une
christian bale benicio del toro kate
blanchett et rooney mara et voilà donc
cesser jeu j'en sais peu aussi on ne
sait pas le titre du film et du coup
j'ai hâte que j'aurai la surprise aussi
pour je pense ce sera en septembre la
sortie probablement de découvrir ce
qu'il a fait de tout ça et coupe on
verra ça fait partie des risques du
métier de la vie
tu as retrousse